you play what's a quasi superhero in
these movies so what I did was I pulled
some single lines from some characters
that you could easily fit into awesome
Sergei perfect right here we go the
first one is Guy Gardner the belligerent
Green Lantern who once got in a fight
with Batman and Batman took him out with
one punch
excuse me screw excuse me excuse me oh
that's an al-qaeda something's going
overs now excuse me screwloose but the
names Guy Gardner the one true Green
Lantern and when it comes to wielding
power you ain't seeing nothing to them
hard
that's unbelievable okay look at one
more green arrow from Dark Knight
Returns so this is an old grizzled green
arrow who the government like me yeah
got the result yeah the government is
going to has been trying to capture him
for years
Batman's on the wrong side of law at
this point so green arrow has lost his
arm presumably Superman took his arm off
you know what I shouldn't read it once
for I should just go for it right should
I only have one arm right my students
this is a man who commits this is why
everybody wants to work with over this
ready here we go go and they've been
covering me just like they covered up my
escape sure they'd love to frost me when
it all comes down
I want a piece of a small piece will do
for a little time's sake you know
it's still hurting school your ass oh
yeah yes people pump arms absolutely
tremendous this shows it captain Marvin
okay can I say something please
I broke my foot Marv my ankle when I was
three years old because I jumped off a
jungle gym and screamed Shazam cuz
that's what he said when he started to
fly yeah I didn't know she's an was in
the diss as a whole new Captain Marvel
is the character and his the word he
says to change from a little boy Billy
Batson into Captain Marvel issues and
it's one word that's the only one you
have to deliver this is the one that I
broke my leg with this goes too deep
shows I am you're still the best this is
Jason Bourne this Sunday AMC is geeking
out hosts Kevin Smith and Greg Grunberg
hang out with Jason Bourne's Matt Damon
Jason Bourne's a superhero but one who's
one of us why would come back now these
same things he knows things the purpose
of it is business geeking out the Comic
Con special Sunday at 10:00 only on AMC
and don't miss Jason Bourne in theaters
July 29th